how can anyone justify this
bresnihuvate secondary school hit by two
rockets
one of them crushed the front reception
the walls slumped into the children's
cloakroom
our library thankfully the 500 children
who attend this school were long gone
but every window is blown
every classroom smashed
how do you feel standing in your school
when it looks like this
my heart is broken
because
[Music]
i'm very sad
and very angry
you don't see many children in the
villages and towns east of mikolive the
ones from this school have dispersed far
and wide some to the uk so that was
geography yes geographic evident
this is where the second rocket hit but
one thing did survive intact which
helena sees as a message
we will win
because the only thing that survived was
a map
of ukraine yes the map's title says
united ukraine yeah
the un estimates that two-thirds of
ukraine's children have fled their homes
since the russian invasion unicef
calling it the fastest displacement of
children since world war ii
what does this war mean for the children
of ukraine all our children
understand
is that that war
only destroyed
and we
we have a dream
that our school
will be
rebuilt
and we
thank you
no it's okay
we
it is the first time i
i cried
the un has verified that 153 children
have been killed in this war though the
number is almost certainly much higher
two had a lucky escape in this house
the family including children aged 16
and 10 were rescued from under the
rubble by locals who ran to help
neighbor valentina would flee the town
but she has her animals and a bed-bound
elderly mother to look after meanwhile
her niece in moscow tells her it's all
justified
my sons are in the army the first the
second they both are and what are they
bombing themselves and she said yes
that's what you get you are fascists on
the donbas you tortured people for eight
years and now you get what you deserve
but for eight years donbass was not
destroyed but now look what's happened
there everything is destroyed they have
zombified people to the point that they
don't want to listen to anything else
perhaps news doesn't reach moscow that
in the first five weeks of the war an
average of 22 schools were attacked
every day
russia says its attacks are all on
military targets this one was a school
and guess what it still is
online lessons to its pupils have
restarted this week
jason farrell sky news bereznevata